the main idea upon the european semester
is to ensure
that a series of economic targets and
growth tension measures are implemented
by the member states
in real terms what that means is that
this is a tool
to create jobs to promote sustainable
growth to get europe back to economic
accessibility and recovery
and these are the key priorities
actually of the irish presidency so this
is why
it's quite a natural fit for the irish
presence to ensure that the european
semester
is run as smoothly and as effectively as
possible so we meet the successful
goal of adopting the current country
pacific recommendations
uh by by june it is in fact a governance
structure to ensure that
the targets economic targets that have
been set up by the european council are
achieved
by the member states and the eu as a
whole by the 2020 deadline that we've
set ourselves
and it does this through first of all
starting with the annual growth survey
that's prepared by the commission in
november and then through
a process of consultation and
orientations given by the echo finn and
ebsco council and by the european
council and member states prepare
national reform programmes
and as on the basis of that then the
commission will prepare country pacific
recommendations
that give policy guidance to member
states on how to achieve these economic
targets and they in turn feed into the
preparation of their national budgets
each year in a legal sense it's not
binding
but certainly in a political sense it's
binding there are consequences if the
member states fail to implement the csrs
and there is an intense period of
monitoring and peer review within the
council to ensure that member states
implement the csrs
and but there's also mechanisms
available to the commission
and to give policy warnings if the cso
is not implemented within a certain
period of time
and also there's possibility of
sanctions or incentives
in this time where we're dealing with an
economic crisis we're trying to find
ways to
enhance growth and create jobs and the
main thing for the european
semester to do is to implement the
targets we set ourselves to make sure
that we create jobs and create growth
and they do this through a series of
events
and that not only monitor the
implementation of the
of the recommendations given to member
states and would also develop these
recommendations uh to ensure that
there's economic convergence among the
member states and that the member states
put in place um
key growth enhancing measures to create
jobs and growth within the member states
themselves it's quite easy for member
states to blame brussels
and but at the at the end of it it's all
about making sure that the
policies economically of each member
state is sustainable
and that that economic policy then is
sustainable into the future to create
jobs
sustainable jobs and sustainable growth
and so in the end of the day i think the
european union is very much in
the business of trying to help each
member state and not trying to punish
each member state
and without what's good for the member
states is good for the european union as
a whole which is good for the citizens
in terms of jobs
and growth